who are the celebrities you always get
mistaken it's from the beginning i was
mistaken for willem dafoe oh yeah right
right away right yeah so as soon as i
got famous i was in an airport one day
guy walked up he said hey man can i have
your autograph and i go yeah i was like
so like [ __ ] puffed up and full of
life because you really had a lot of
fame from mtv yeah
right exactly right so i [ __ ] signed
you know you know what do you want me
whatever his name was i write bill you
know all the best dennis leary and he
looks at it and he and like i thought
maybe i signed it too messy he goes what
the [ __ ] is that and i go
what's my autograph he goes
who are you i go dennis leary he goes i
thought you were william defoe and he
[ __ ] he throws the
thing in the trash he's mad at you right
so then shortly thereafter uh i started
getting mistaken occasionally for kevin
bacon that i see okay yeah so i'm like i
don't think i look like kevin bacon but
i get it a tall lanky guy whatever right
right so okay kevin bacon kevin bacon
and dafoe and default both great so far
not too terrible [ __ ] great actors
right right so i'm i'm actually getting
mistaken up right right uh so the i
think the third person is it started to
happen when i was doing the rock and
roll show at uh you know sex and drugs
and rock and roll facts i had my hair
grown up in kind of a shag right and the
character used to wear like you know
unisexual clothing and so i would have
like women sunglasses like jackie on
acid so one day i'm shooting a scene
with a woman's leather jacket on uh
jackie o'nasa's sunglasses and a ton of
jewelry and you know a shag haircut yeah
and we have the whole block blocked off
in this police barricades and i'm
walking down the street this woman goes
oh my god i'm your biggest fan and i'm
like oh hey cause there's a ton of fans
there and she goes but i have to go i
have to go to work can i get a picture i
go yeah so i take her out of the
barricade she comes over i'm so again
puffed up and full of myself i take this
[ __ ] selfie with her and she goes oh
my god glee is my favorite show and
you're my favorite character and then
she gets in a cab and i'm like she
[ __ ] thinks i'm jane lynch right
and i seem to get rid of that chance
yeah i see this [ __ ] flake glass
window and i realize i look like jane
[ __ ] right
dude like jane lynch when you're a rock
star now yeah that's
this is number three this is also true
i'm making a [ __ ] football movie
called draft day in cleveland right
we're shooting in cleveland at the
cleveland browns facility i'm playing
the coach i got a [ __ ] short haircut
i'm wearing chinos which i never wear in
real life right and uh you know like
[ __ ] t-shirt and a sport coat that's
my character's you know look
and i come out one day to go to work and
i'm [ __ ] wearing the character pants
and i got a sport coat on a really short
haircut and i'm not kidding you i mean
there's lesbians everywhere i walk out
and there's lesbians getting off of you
know lesbian buses as like lesbians
signing up lesbians they're always
giving lesbian badges and i'm like
waiting for my driver and i'm like what
the hell is going on here and i swear to
god a woman goes oh my god ellen you got
mistaken for alan
now women are you're getting mistaken
i'm women
so i go
for ellen degeneres i go okay what the
[ __ ] this is very emasculated but i
don't i don't say i don't say i'm not
ellen first i go what what's going on
here it was a convention it was like
there was a big parade and it was a
lesbian convention and i was like you
should have just gone with it yeah
people [ __ ] love ellen oh yeah
for the four seconds i was alan people
were freaking out you had never had
congratulations as soon as i said i was
dennis larry is that really true yeah
you should have danced yeah she loves i
know i can't dance that well